today we are talking about diversian
inclusion a highly available storage
launch and a frequently requested
training this is stephanie wong and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
diversity equity and inclusion dei are
more than just buzzwords they are
critical components of workplace culture
that have real tangible impacts on your
entire organization not only because it
enhances your ability to be responsive
to users and customers but because it
builds trust and a sense of belonging
for your employees
read our short ebook to learn steps you
can take to build dei into your business
along with insights from our journey at
google cloud
we recently announced file store
enterprise a fully managed cloud native
nfs solution that lets you confidently
deploy critical file-based applications
in google cloud backed by a service
level agreement that delivers
99.99
regional availability to get started
with file store enterprise register for
our webinar explore what's new with
google cloud storage on october 6 and
google cloud next
inf206
breakout session where you'll hear from
real users about their modernization
journey
you asked for it and we listened we're
excited to announce the cloud digital
leader learning pathway our first
offering for business professionals that
includes both training and certification
the cloud digital leader learning
pathway is designed to skill up
individuals and teams that work with
technical google cloud practitioners so
they can contribute to strategic
cloud-related business decisions check
out the blog to learn more and sign up
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list then
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud